[Musique]
grosse honte de lancer votre chaîne,
alors juste une mise à jour rapide pour tout le monde au
cas où vous seriez confus, il n'y a pas d'animateur
ce soir, il n'y aura pas de catégorie de film populaire
et le Mexique ne paie pas pour que
le mur passe en deuxième  nomination forme
un allié personnel mon partenaire Vigo
arme extraordinaire et Peter Farrelly
vous remercient pour votre leadership et vos
conseils et pour nous avoir également donné de l'espace
[Applaudissements]
cinquième nomination pour Spike Lee avant
le monde ce soir, je reçois des éloges sur nos
ancêtres 12 ont construit ce pays et ont été
aujourd'hui, avec le génocide de son
peuple autochtone, l'élection présidentielle de 2020
approche à grands pas,
mobilisons-nous tous, soyons tous du bon côté
de l'histoire, faisons le choix moral entre
l'amour et la haine, faisons ce qu'il faut,
tu sais, je devais le faire comprendre  là je
n'arrive pas à croire qu'un film sur les menstruations vient de
remporter un Oscar Lady Gaga Martin
Bradlee il n'y a pas une seule personne sur
la planète qui aurait pu chanter cette
chanson avec moi mais merci d'
avoir cru en nous merci beaucoup
[Musique]
dans le hangar ou nous sommes loin du hangar
Oscar va à
Rami Malek Merci Reine merci les
gars de m'avoir permis d'être la
plus petite partie de votre
héritage extraordinaire et phénoménal Je vous suis éternellement
redevable
et nous avons fait un film sur un  un homme gay, un
immigrant qui a lui-même vécu sa vie
sans vergogne. Je suis le fils d'
immigrés égyptiens. Je suis un
Américain de première génération et l'Oscar
revient à Olivia Colman.
C'est le premier Oscar et la première nomination
pour Olivia Colman. C'est vraiment assez
stressant.
Yoko est ma  meilleur réalisateur dans le meilleur film
et avec Emily et Rachel les deux
plus belles femmes du monde avec qui tomber
amoureux de lui pour aller travailler tous
les jours, je veux dire, vous pouvez imaginer que ce n'était pas une
difficulté Glenn Close, c'est-à-dire que vous avez été mon
idole depuis si longtemps et ce n'est pas comme ça que je
voulais que ça soit et je pense que tu es
incroyable et puis nous sommes vraiment mes enfants
à la maison en train de regarder, regarde bien si tu
ne l'es pas, alors nous sommes plutôt bien faits mais je fais le
tri  j'espère que tu es que ça ne se
reproduira plus
Oh Lady Gaga
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes comme ça, Deacon l'a eu
et l'Oscar va à son nom Je n'arrive pas à
prononcer Alfonso Cuarón
Je veux remercier l'Académie d'avoir
reconnu un centre de cinéma  autour d'une
femme indigène l'une des soixante-dix
millions de travailleuses domestiques dans le monde
ayant un droit au travail un personnage
historiquement relégué au
second plan dans le cinéma gracias gracias gracias
et sérieusement Charlie ne me botte toujours pas le
cul et l'Oscar revient à Green Book
[Applaudissements]
et d'ailleurs, cela ne commence pas
sans Viggo Mortensen,
là, nous n'avons pas de film, toutes ces
récompenses sont parce que Vigo, toute l'histoire
est une question d'amour, il s'agit de s'aimer les uns les
autres malgré nos différences et de
découvrir la vérité sur qui nous  sommes-
nous les mêmes prix, félicitations à
tous les nominés et bonne nuit à la
mère de Bradley Cooper
et à mes enfants et merci d'avoir
regardé